week and watch for the authors in the
near future on book tv
salon.com co-founder david talbot is
next on book tv
his book the devil's chessboard focuses
on the dulles brothers alan dulles the
longest serving director of the cia
and john foster dulles secretary of
state under president eisenhower
so david a couple of announcements to
start off things i think oh well here no
not announcement but
just a few uh introductory remarks
maybe to set the stage for our
conversation patrick
uh
and uh what you want to introduce me
first well this is uh this is david
talbot and i'm patrick marks this is my
little shop the green arcade you've
probably been here before or maybe not
and uh thank you we just celebrated
seven years here
and david has been a part of it actually
uh david was uh born in uh los angeles
and uh cabin
and befitting a legend we don't know
what year that was
but uh and he you know his father was
lyle taba talbot who was an amazing
heartthrob
and uh and an actor and a and uh
according to his sister margaret who
wrote this book
the entertainer
uh quite a guy and it was quite a family
and his uh brother steve was also a
really interesting guy who was a
a fantastic documentarist video maker
was very uh well known for doing um
the frontline series and also
to the baby boomers he was known as
gilbert and leave it to beaver yes yes
we were a sitcom family
so uh
david was a journalist he worked during
the heyday for crawdaddy
wow that's that yeah
i remember
who remembers cried out of here the
great
rock and roll magazine rolling stone you
probably know rolling stone and uh
editor mother jones which is still going
doing really well and interviewed david
for the this book uh the devil's chess
board and i was at the examiner
and then he was one of the first people
to sort of
say oh my god the internet exists maybe
we can do journalism on it and he
started salon.com
which is still going and is still a
vital
organ can i use that word
but
so his book season of the witch which
you might know
if i can hold up the prop and yeah there
are several
major fans of this book not only san
francisco but throughout the country
and this book has recently been chosen
as
the one city one book for the city of
san francisco by the san francisco
public library it's compulsory that you
read it
you must it's the law
it's on the muni bus tells you to read
it i mean you know something's going on
then
uh and then he also was the author of
the best-selling book uh the brothers
and the brothers
which i think is uh we can talk you know
you let us know about this later but the
it's the hidden history of the kennedy
years
so this idea of hidden history i think
is sort of what we're kind of here
tonight and what eventually led to the
devil's chess board i would say is that
correct yeah
that's a safe statement now he's also
one more thing if i can go on to with
the introduction is that david is also
amidst all these
things he's been doing he's also
involved in
in the civic uh matters recently
with a group called vision sf
and i don't know if you've heard of that
but if you haven't you might look into
it and it has to do with
i don't know for lack of a better word
taking back our city yes
from the one percent
as if that's not enough
when do you have time to go to zuni
um
i can always squeeze that in he's also
working now on uh or actually it's
already going and it's a new uh series
uh called hot books and the first book
has come out and it's called the beast
inside the beast i'm sorry the beast
side the beast side it's all that dulles
stuff yeah exactly living and dying
while black in america and this book is
uh just a fantastic book and a very
important commentary in our lives today
here in this country and there's a
couple other books coming out soon is
that true yeah we can talk about that
later okay
so without further ado let's get to
the
devil's chess board
now like the uh
subtitle is alan dulles
the cia and the rise of america's secret
government
so can you tell us how you got from the
brothers to
the devil's chess board
well with your permission uh patrick i
was just i'm going to start with a few
remarks of my own and then we get into
conversation mode but i i wanted to set
the stage by talking about uh what i was
trying to do with the book
um
it's it's basically a counter narrative
about power
you know power tells its own story power
is its best publicist
power is its best spinner of the truth
and of history
and uh we've seen this again and again
throughout our lives people my
generation
and many of the people here
saddam was behind 911. saddam was
producing weapons of mass destruction
the north vietnamese fired on u.s ships
in the gulf of tonkin
lee harvey oswald
single-handedly killed john f kennedy no
fidel castro killed john f kennedy
these are the stories that power has
told about
itself throughout my lifetime
the essentially these are the real
conspiracy theories
and they're told by power
with the
complicity of the american media the
corporate media and these are the
stories that have had unfortunately some
tragic consequences as well as we all
know
from the examples that i just cited
so it's the job of people like me
uh historians
alternative historians journalists
to present
the truth
basically to cut through this
myth-making
uh this uh spinning of history
of reality
and
you know it's it's no easy task because
there's hollywood
there's
the corporate media there's fox news
and again and again day after day 24 7
they're telling us their reality
and as steve mills the great sociologist
who wrote the power elite back during
the cold war in the 1950s and was one of
the first
to really analyze the phenomenon of the
dulles brothers and that power circle
as he famously said about these men such
men as these because they were 99 men in
those days and probably 96 today
such men as these are crackpot realists
in the name of
realism or reality they've created a
paranoid reality reality all of their
own
and we're forced to live within that
paranoid reality
it's the communists out to kill us
it's uh you know uh
people living in a cave somewhere in
afghanistan
there's always a bogeyman there's always
someone that we have to fear
and as a result of that they've created
a lucrative racket and that's what it is
that's that's what happened during the
cold war that's what's happening during
the war on terror
so it's the job of people like myself
it's the job of of you all of an engaged
citizenry to see through that mythology
to do the work to do the research to
know what's really happening in our
country and make the right decisions
by the end of reading my book and i hope
you read the book
i hope you
believe as i do that the name dulles
should go down in infamy in american
history
just like the name kissinger the name
cheney the name rumsfeld these are names
that should be stripped off uh the every
building every airport
dulles airport and replaced with the
names of true american heroes like
martin luther king and others
and so tonight i want to announce a
campaign to do exactly that to take the
name dulles it was named after john
foster dulles who has his own criminal
background
uh the brother of alan dels who was
secretary of state under eisenhower take
that name off the name of our nation's
capital airport where so many people
thousands of people each day come from
around the world it's the gateway to our
country
and it's a name that should instead as i
say go down in infamy
and be replaced by
a name that stands for peace and world
harmony
so
with that
well
opening statement
let's have a talk well one of the things
you know
is this my water bottle yes it is okay
one of the things i'm wondering about is
the process of of doing that of doing
the research
of what
in doing this book where did you go and
what did you do and
and
how much were you aware of initially
i've read the book so if you haven't
you'll be you might think you know a lot
of
these stories about uh the cia
unsettling governments of assassination
of
extraordinary rendition
but how did you where did you go did you
travel around did you
meet people
who talked did you
go to archives i know karen croft one of
your your partners uh did a lot of work
and you were in italy
yup yup we did a lot of work karen croft
who is my colleague and collaborator is
here tonight i couldn't have done the
book without her uh
and
since the book really begins uh with the
nazi period with alan dulles going to
switzerland during world war ii as a
member uh as a leading uh you know agent
of the oss which was our spy agency
during world war ii of course we're
dealing with you know history that is
quite old at this point in terms of
trying to find living uh voices who can
tell you about that history and of
course we follow sort of the dallas arc
through world war ii and into the cold
war and then through the kennedy period
and it really is an epic narrative about
as i said earlier the struggle which
we've been living through all our lives
between the forces of secrecy of
permanent war
and the forces of democracy
and uh it's really a battle for the the
soul of our nation
uh so yeah many of the people of course
from that era including ellen dulles
himself of course is long dead but their
children in many cases are still alive
we interviewed ellen dulles's daughter
joan
we interviewed
some key people who are still living
from that period and of course we use
documents the documents that we could
use now that's a whole other game of
course the government plays
as orwell told us in 1984
those who would control the future
control the past and so it's a struggle
for every researcher for every historian
for every journalist who's trying to dig
up the history that belongs to the
american people to get at those
documents and of course the government
often still withholds these documents uh
well you also docum you also talk about
how they just constantly redestroying
documents
well they destroy documents they hide
them they they refuse they you know in
violation often of federal law to
release them uh because of political
pressure there was a bill passed in 1998
under clinton
the nazi war crimes disclosure act and i
did use uh many many documents uh that
were released as part of that treasure
trove but that was only came about
because of stiff political pressure from
elizabeth holtzman who was a
congresswoman at the time
and others in congress
to get the cia to release these
documents that uh what because
they were often embarrassing to our
intelligence agencies because what many
of these documents showed and what my
book goes into in depth is the extent to
which u.s security agencies were
actually collaborating uh with nazi
forces even during the war in the case
of allen dallas in switzerland and
certainly after the war
when we wanted to repurpose
many of these nazi officials for the war
against the soviet union the cold war
so yeah it's always a battle sometimes
you have to file freedom of information
act lawsuits even that doesn't work
often they stonewall you
we can talk about the kennedy era that's
a whole other story where they
again in violation of federal law the
jfk records act that was passed in the
early 1990s still refused to release key
documents related to the kennedy
presidency and his assassination so it
really is up to the american people to
decide whether we want our own history
it belongs to us are we going to demand
it or not i mean that's what it comes
down to but don't you think at the same
time there's this idea of uh
what you're saying there's this constant
breaking of the law
and there and they get away with it and
dulles got away with it constantly and
he made sure he got away with it and
then also because of the complicity you
know between law making
that type of gov that other government
and let's say the private sector because
they all came from wall street
so we've sort of seen this kind of
complicity
and then eventually you end up with what
you
you call the deep state or maybe that's
peter dale scott's the deep state or but
this concept of another
another
operating now this obviously
uh didn't die with alan dulles do you
think
no i mean uh just leading you on on that
question
yeah i mean again
the uh
these
forces and
it's what sea right mills in the 1950s
called the power elite
the it's a permanent government
essentially uh that operates no matter
who is happens to be elected or in the
white house
uh men like alan dallas thought that
democracy was too important to be left
in the hands of mere people like you and
me or our elected representatives
so they kept power as tightly as they
could within their circle
these were wall street right bankers uh
the dulles brothers ran the most
powerful law firm on wall street
sullivan and cromwell
they
often you know shuttle back and forth
between washington and wall street uh in
national security positions and so on uh
high-level corporate officials military
and intelligence officials they belong
to the same clubs
they their children go to the same
schools they intermarry it's a very
cohesive power circle particularly so i
think in those days maybe it's a little
more diverse a little more complex today
than when sea wright mills was running
the power elite in the late 1950s during
the dulles era
but there's a lot of cohesion and they
work within organizations like the
council on foreign relations
in new york which the dulles brothers
dominated for many years and this is
where they work out their ideas and
their policies whether it's to overthrow
the democratically elected government in
guatemala because it's threatening
u.s corporate interests or whether it's
to drop the bombs nuclear bombs atomic
bombs on japan
or whether it's to kill a president
i think they work these ideas out among
themselves i'm not suggesting that alan
dulles as some superman who went about
you know doing all this mischief around
the world and at home all by himself
he was very much a corporate lawyer in
that respect he would only act i think
when he felt that there was a consensus
within that group
and so they did have the mechanisms like
the council on foreign relations and
others and they still do to work out
this policy
and of course most of this if not all of
it uh in many cases is kept secret from
the american people so you know and that
leads us to the idea of the fifth estate
now let's say that uh
like we're always talking about now how
the
um
the journalism has it's more difficult
uh but you know in reading your book it
seems that
the new york times was in their pocket
and there was very little this it seems
that dissent was not
didn't really come from
not the media yeah the media was not the
watchdogs
they should be and there really wasn't a
watchdog and even though you know you do
point out that even in the highest
circle as a power like within the white
house
these guys were doing their own thing
and they were beyond the law well the
media was actually part of this power
circle so i should say that you know
among the other members of the council
on foreign relations are often the top
executives of the new york times the
washington post uh cbs and so on and
they're all on a first name basis a very
chummy basis with alan dulles in fact he
would hold these annual kind of drink
fests
around new year's each
year where he would invite the top
people top reporters and editors and
executives from these uh leading media
organizations at his club his club is
called the alibi club which was
appropriate uh
and so
it was very cozy a very cozy
relationship and so when people said
well certainly these things would have
been exposed by the american media i
mean we have this very vast you know
kind of media apparatus and you know i
always laugh about that as someone who
spent my whole life in the media and
knowing you know how compromised
actually most uh
people uh in these media organizations
are compromised by power
and you know even today you know the new
york times was very complicit of course
in the wmd lives uh
that led tragically to the war in iraq
and to the ongoing uh disaster uh that's
going on the middle east today but
certainly back in alan dulles's time i
mean you can go into his files as i did
and karen and i in princeton uh and you
know the files are largely purged of
course of the you know the most
probably revealing stuff by the cia but
there still is a lot in there that's
very interesting and among other things
are his very chummy letters back and
forth with these media figures at the
new york times and newsweek and so on
he's ally to them i mean you know he has
nicknames for them uh one letter after
uh the warren report came out and he was
of course a very important figure on the
warren report some people thought he
dominated to the extent that it should
be called the dulles commission not the
warren commission
and after this is a letter from the
washington bureau chief i believe of
newsweek to allen dolls
after the war report came out saying
dear mr dolls thank you so much for
directing our coverage basically of the
warren commission of the warren report
we couldn't have done it under such a
tight deadline without your guiding hand
you know
so um it's right there to be read in
these files
so uh
just to bring it up to the president
so how
how has this book been how do you feel
your book has been posited or been
received and can you talk a little bit
about that even in your hometown they're
gobsmacked media
because it's been interesting i yeah
again i've read some of them so i was
wondering how you feel about that
because some of them have been really
rather strange i think
well if i hadn't shocked the media i
don't think i would have done my job i
mean you know they are the gatekeepers
they
as i start off with my introductory
marks by saying
they have an interest in telling a
certain version about america and
so this is a counter story a counter
narrative
and uh so the
yeah there's been great resistance to
the book from the media gatekeepers i've
been told that uh the washington post is
not going to review it but i slipped one
by them there and i actually wrote an
op-ed piece that it did appear in the
washington post
so you do what you can do it's guerrilla
warfare um i was on my way to al jazeera
america in a car in manhattan a week or
so ago on my book tour i was lined up by
you know to do an interview
in new york for al jazeera american
suddenly my publicist got a
email saying it's been cancelled
and when he asked why he was surprised
of course he got a one-word reply and
through the email politics
so they were pretty upfront about it uh
politico
the um
online publication uh started by former
washington post people has become sort
of the voice online for mainstream
political coverage they had me lined up
to do something one of the key people
there
who
actually is a very good reporter called
my book a masterpiece and said that he
wanted me very badly to write something
based on the book for politico but
someone above him spiked it at the last
moment and instead
ran a piece by a guy named phil shenan
who was a former new york times reporter
who has been peddling a cia
disinformation line for some time now
mainly that fidel castro was behind the
murder of president kennedy which is
literally the oldest conspiracy theory
there is about jfk's assassination and
complete bs
so uh you know that's what happens it's
a war writing is fighting i didn't exp i
didn't expect anything different from
this book
but the fact is that it's not a media
monolith we
people like us have ways to get uh
messages out there's alternative media
there's democracy now there's pacifica
radio there's mother jones there's salon
which was why i started salon to have an
alternative voice like that
and because of that the book has now
become a bestseller which i'm very proud
of despite this pushback great yeah
that's what i wanted to hear you say
right on
and it's uh doing i think it started
taking off philly california for some
reason is that correct california led
the way yeah it became a bestseller here
first
and northern california first so this i
don't know if this is a
silly question or not but uh can i ask a
possible silly question of course
so it has to do with extraordinary
rendition so
do you
in reading this book i these people the
and the the effect still of
i can see why you called it the devil's
chessboard because they really were
playing
with nations with people and the effects
so many of them were deaths suicide
nations and
you know
crumbled
you know a legacy of ashes as you know
the term goes so
were you
to do you guys ever fear for your own
life
you mean you think i'll end up at
guantanamo well i
uh probably not as a public figure it's
more difficult these days i don't know
i'm just curious you know does that
thought
even reading it sometimes you think oh
god it's
creepy
well again my my the point is to have an
impact uh to shift uh the public's
understanding of what's happening in our
country
uh this is not just ancient history this
is history that's still very relevant
today extraordinary rendition torture
extra-legal assassinations mass
surveillance of private citizens all of
these began not after 9 11 but under the
reign of alan dulles back in the cold
war so for us to understand that cold
war history is essential for us to
confront what's going on our country
today so do i worry about my own self no
i worry about what's still happening to
people in pakistan people in afghanistan
to our own soldiers who are asked to
fight these endless wars uh under
impossible circumstances
uh so that's what drives me it's it's
that this is on my conscience just as on
my soul as an american as an as a
journalist and historian like i know
it's on all of our consciences here
tonight and we have to say finally
enough
and it's my job to give us the
information and and there's other
wonderful people out there doing the
same people i worked with at salon like
glenn greenwald who's an american hero
jeremy scahill many others doing the
same and that's why i started this new
book in print hot books to be able to
publish more books like this that shed
light on what's happening to our country
today but at some point we do have to
say enough you know the presidential
campaign is underway right now and
there's no focus at all on these issues
that ed snowden tried to bring forth uh
you know about the the growth of this
big brother state that has intruded into
every aspect of our lives well this uh
you know the hearing with hillary
clinton with uh benghazi there was no
mention of what the actual thing was
right there was no talk about why are we
there what what why why why
why do they hate us that's a good
question well exactly i mean we're
shocked that people uh when we start to
have heavy boots in all these countries
and interfere in all these other
countries we're shocked that actually
people fire guns at us in our emissaries
and and try to kill us i mean this
should not be shocking the american
people or that there's atrocities like
the hospital afghanistan that was run by
doctors without borders that
children and nurses and and doctors are
blown up uh in these attacks that are
supposedly collateral damage well
collateral damage is an essential part
of an imperial uh situation an imperial
war that we are constantly fighting
that's what happens in these situations
we are our representatives our soldiers
are killed and to a much greater extent
the civilians in these poor uh benighted
countries
where we've intruded where we've invaded
uh die by the thousands
and so again uh
this is a legacy of the alan dulles
imperial arrogance of this country that
we have a right to the world that's what
they felt like coming out of world war
two they had a right to the world we
have a right to the world's markets we
have a right to the world's resources we
have a right to do whatever we want to
people around the world who are less
powerful than we are
and at some point we and you know you
have to understand there's going to be
blowback there's going to be
consequences
and
you know the american people need to
wake up to this and i hope my book is at
least a small part of that awakening
so the let me ask you then about uh
one of the hot books i think the topic
is about the war criminals
yeah but they're gonna just kind of fit
right in
well right uh so hot books is this new
imprint i've started with sky horse
publishing which is a very brave and
independent uh publisher in new york
run by a publisher named tony lyons
and one of our first books after the
beast side which we talked about earlier
is a book called american nuremberg and
it's been written by a philosophy
professor at usf university of san
francisco
right here rebecca gordon
and she wrote a book earlier for oxford
university press called mainstreaming
torture that looked at how we've
become culturally uh
you know accustomed now to accepting
torture in our name as as part of u.s
policy and this book she looks at the
top u.s officials in both the bush and
obama administrations
from those presidents on down from
president bush and president obama
themselves
who should by the principles and
standards that were set at nuremberg
after world war ii
be tried for war crimes
and it's a very restrained very uh
i think uh
provocative uh argument for why we
should hold at least a citizen's
tribunal because politically of course
we know it's impossible to create
something official like nuremberg it
there's just not enough uh political
opportunity for obvious reasons to do
that in this country but there are
precedents like the
russell tribunal that bertrand russell
british philosopher established during
the 1960s with jean-paul sartre
to examine war crimes in vietnam this
was a very distinguished commission back
in 1967
and i think again for the soul of our
country for our own conscience we have
to take steps
as uh as an engaged citizenry to do
something like this
to examine what's been done in the last
15 years
under the so-called war on terror in our
names i agree so listen uh you you tell
the story about jesus uh galindez
jesus de galindez yes and i was
wondering if you could just tell a story
because i i wanted to read a quote that
happened after that if you
well so you bring up extraordinary
rendition again nothing new here uh this
was not an invention of dick cheney and
don remsfeld uh it was actually a
creation of the cia during the cold war
so in one of the first cases of
extraordinary rendition that i'm aware
of it's a remarkable story there was a
young uh brilliant scholar
named jesus de galindez who was a
refugee from basque spain he fled
franco's fascist government after the
war
ended up unfortunately jumping out of
the frying pan into the fire because he
ended up in the dominican republic
which was then under the brutal rule of
rafael trujillo
uh when he fell afoul of the trujillo
dictatorship he fled there and ended up
in new york city where he was studying
for his phd in colombia and working as a
lecturer at columbia
well he his phd thesis was about
actually an inside look because he'd had
some inside information about the
brutality of the trujillo dictatorship
and trujillo's agents were everywhere he
was a very uh
powerful guy
backed strongly by the eisenhower
government by the cia because he was a
supposedly anti-communist that's all you
had to be in those days to get u.s
backing
and his agents stalked uh
galindez in new york city they showed up
his classrooms and tried to intimidate
him
they tried to threaten him into uh
stopping uh you know seizing work on his
his thesis
but he uh refused and so one day he was
uh headed home
uh downtown from columbia and he was
grabbed by agents who actually went
under the employ of the cia these were
cia contractors
he was hustled to uh airport in on long
island and flown back to the dominican
republic where he was horribly tortured
and and murdered by trujillo
so this is what extraordinary rendition
is and this happened uh in the 1950s not
you know after the 9 11. and then i
guess other this is from your book when
you're one of the students from columbia
who i think his name was joy what was
your name maria joy
one of his students yeah yeah and she
wrote if this can happen here what is
left
everybody who has some sense of
responsibility and a feeling for
democracy and freedom
should be concerned and i just thought
that
is what your book is all about yeah that
was absolutely i thought there was a
very moving letter that she wrote i
think to the new republic was it was the
new republic yeah in trying to get
people to be concerned about this case
because at that point they didn't know
where galindos had gone he'd been
disappeared
but of course they had
suspicions about what had happened to
him and the eyes on how actually even
president eisenhower was asked about his
disappearance during a press conference
and he kind of
avoided answering um
columbia university was kind of
complicit in a way because the president
grayson kirk at the time
was uh sat on commissions and and
foundations that were supported by the
cia
the columbia administration did nothing
to look into the glenda's case so it you
know it's again one of these
dark uh episodes from the cia history
that we write about in in the devil's
chessboard but again i just think that
this concern is why we're all here
and why you do what you do
and i also wanted to say you know ask
you um what
what is new
that you really what's the newest thing
that you found out in doing this that
you found most relevatory
well i think the the key
sort of uh headlines from my book began
with the nazi period began with the
extent to which alan dulles and his
circle his intelligence circle
collaborated with the nazis before in
the case of sullivan and cromwell the
wall street law firm because they
represented nazi business interests
including ig farben the notorious
chemical company that produced zyklon b
the pesticide that was used to
exterminate
jews and you know they're exchanging
christmas cards the dulles brothers with
the heads of ig farben up into actually
into the early war
period uh
dulles from his perch in switzerland
during the war continue to represent
nazi interests he was trying to cut
deals
side deals in defiance of
roosevelt's policy of unconditional
surrender with nazi emissaries
separate peace deals after the war he
helps establish the so-called rat lines
that were escape routes for nazi war
criminals that were set up
so they could flee from germany over the
alps down through italy and overseas to
safety
he even helped uh rehabilitate some of
the more notorious nazi war criminals
allowing them to go back
into
daily life even official life in west
germany post-war germany
the top spymaster in west germany i tell
the stories reinhard galen
who was hitler's top spymaster on the
bloody eastern front
and uh
alan dell's helped install him as the
top intelligence official
in west german government he played a
very important role in the cold war for
many years so that's number one the
collaboration with the nazis
i argue in some ways that we didn't
crush the third reich so much as
repurpose it for the cold war
secondly there's a lot of things in the
cold war period that i go into that
haven't come out before
uh including the fact that we targeted
not only
governments in guatemala which we know
about iran which was with great
disastrous results that we're still
dealing with today
but even the
the government of an ally president
charles de gaulle in france
uh antagonized national security
interests in this country in dallas in
particular
by trying to settle the war in algeria
the colonial war um u.s national
security interests were concerned they
thought that algeria and north africa
with its oil might fall into soviet
hands as a result they thought de gaulle
was too stubborn a nationalist he was
flirting with the idea of breaking away
from nato and so on and so in 1961 on
the heels of the
one other cia crisis the bay of pigs
invasion of cuba
young president kennedy who's just been
inaugurated a couple months before is
now faced with another crisis related to
the cia charles de gaulle and his
government are
furious are screaming that the cia is
backing a right-wing french military
coup against him
and uh president kennedy's put in the
extremely awkward position
of telling the de gaulle government well
i'm not in control of the cia i can't
speak for them i'm not supporting this
coup but i'm not i can't speak for the
cia
and then finally i think the the big
headline of course in my book that's
getting a lot of pushback from
the uh
media gatekeepers
looks at alan dulles's involvement in
the kennedy assassination itself de
gaulle by the way felt that
these dulles forces were behind the
assassination of president kennedy he
told his information minister when he
came back from the funeral of john
kennedy that the same national security
forces in the us that targeted me killed
president kennedy
that has never been really reported in
this country
that book has never even been translated
it was a memoir by de gaulle's
information minister that he wrote that
was published in france never translated
in the u.s
so that's uh very important i present i
think very compelling new evidence that
ties dulles to the assassination and of
course to the cover-up because he played
such a critical role on the warren
commission i mean how convenient this
guy had been fired by president kennedy
after the bay of pigs a bitter enemy of
the president ends up being the top
investigator into his crime into his
murder
i mean this is the way that this power
group worked with again the complicity
or laziness of the american media
absolutely
maybe we you want to turn it over to the
i was going to say you know so let's
have a big hand for david
thank you thank you
and we'd like to know if you want to do
a little q a here if you do if you could
come up and talk into the microphone
that would be great and we also would
like to make sure it's a question and uh
not a statement if that's possible
i know people sort of
save a statement at the end
but
so
anybody like to come out okay you need
to come up and talk if you want you want
to ask
this one
i just noticed what came out with along
with your book was about another rerun
of uh
gary webb and i was wondering if you'd
like to talk about connections across
those two the journalists very well yeah
uh so the question was about the
journalist gary webb who uh wrote uh the
dark alliance was that was called yeah
he as a reporter for the san jose
mercury he investigated um
the
connection between uh cia and the
contras uh in central america
and how they allowed the contras to run
drugs into this country to help finance
their activities there
uh
and
it was a uh
a bombshell when that
story broke
uh
he came under heavy fire from the cia
as a result of it and heavy pressure
ultimately from his own newspaper and
from the american media that kind of
went after him instead of pursuing the
story itself
and he ended up being you know uh
his career ended up being ruined and it
was uh
i think one of the great tragedies of
american journalism that here's you know
one of the great truth tellers one of
the brave uh investigative journalists
and uh
you know instead of winning the awards
that he should have won his career was
ruined and he ended up actually
uh committing suicide
so the uh
the their you know i i was at salon at
the time i think one of the great
regrets i have actually is not
being tuned in enough to that story as
it was happening to hire gary webb and
and put him to work because
those kind of uh talented and intrepid
journalists are far too
few
and i would have loved to have given him
another
safety raft
um and when i saw it read about read
about his story by uh because it was
written by by nicholas scow who was
actually a very good reporter kill the
messenger it later became a great movie
with jeremy renner starring as gary webb
you should all see the movie and read
the book and in fact
because of karen croft i signed up
nicolas scow to write a book for me for
the hot book series
well
i'll tell you about ellie okay
you're on a need to know basis patrick
yeah it's still it's still in
in a kind of hush-hush mode
cut that out anyway yes so gary webb is
a hero uh and you know unfortunately
he's not with us any longer and i'm
inspired by what he did uh in part by
what i've done with the devil's chess
board
that's great i i'm glad if that people
are making that connection somebody else
like to come up and ask a question
you could come up and ask a question
it'd be good usually we talk loud
that's not good
we're going through if you could come up
and if you want to
so you're asking if gary webb did indeed
commit suicide
yeah there's definitely some uh
some you know
ways about the way he's supposedly
committed suicide that have raised
questions i i'm sorry sir i just don't
know enough about the details to go into
it
so let's let's we'll leave it there
other questions here
if presidents don't have the power
the power somewhere else then how could
we as
citizens have a criminal
who would we take take against this
criminal court you know how do we get to
the power not bush or
obama but the real power
that that's a very
you put your finger on the key question
uh how do we go about holding these
people accountable
we are in the democracy nominally uh and
how do we go about uh acting as if uh
the the popular will the public will
matters
so as i said uh
earlier you know obviously we don't
control congress every wing of the
government is in support of the war on
terror every wing of government is in
support of suppressing our own history
of not releasing documents that the
american people have a right to uh we
probably are in a worse situation right
now than we were even in some ways
during the cold war uh because of the
sort of uh you know reign of terror uh
and repression that 911 unleashed
so
what we can do is unfortunately i think
we have to do outside of the mainstream
political arena
we have to i think be inspired as i said
earlier by things like the bertrand
russell commission during the vietnam
war i think that would be an amazing uh
you know step forward
if we could bring together legal
scholars some people from the political
system investigative journalists
experts in constitutional law and so on
uh and bring them together for an for
this public inquiry
into uh you know the war on terror and
the crimes that have been committed in
our name
and and and and you know organize this
in such a way that it got maximum media
exposure
and you know
various public organizations uh
hopefully human rights groups uh
participate in this
i think that would at least begin the
national dialogue that we're missing in
the presidential campaign i mean these
issues aren't being discussed at all
even by bernie sanders as far as i can
know bernie has done a wonderful job of
focusing on the wealth gap which is
another you know enormous crisis for the
country and and i
uh you know obviously we
you know we have to commend him for
doing that that was desperately needed
also that national discussion but the
national discussion about the permanent
war that we're in and whenever you're in
a permanent war situation it's gonna
it's going to erode democracy at home
you can't have those two things existing
at the same time
because a national security state is
anathema
to a democracy to a healthy democracy so
there's no way that congress is going to
do this on its own we have to act as a
people and i think we created this
public commission the public inquiry in
washington dc
to shame congress and to get as much
media exposure as we could it would at
least initiate this national discussion
that we sorely need at this point
[Applause]
if you don't
with regard to
a national security state being
inconsistent with the democracy
last night on charlie rose ted koppel
uh appeared talking about uh the
possibility of
uh
internet
sabotage and this kind of thing do you
have any comments to make about that i
think that's the beginning he seems to
be launching a campaign
to raise consciousness about this this
uh problem and i i personally don't
think the national security state is
going to go away anytime soon
uh i wonder if you have any thoughts on
koppel's campaign
well i'm not clear about what he's doing
is he trying to suggest that the
internet is a terrorist tool and we have
to crack down on somehow we're very
vulnerable to mass blocked outs you know
right that so they always have some new
scare for us you know some new thing
that we have to hide under the beds and
worry about our bed so you know ted
koppel i think is part of that corporate
media that national security media he
has been his whole career what's
shocking is when some of these guys
actually start to break away from that
consensus you know dan rather gave me a
shout out
dan rather was part of that you know
sort of corporate mainstream world for
many years and then of course had his
own
kind of traumatic break with it uh
following the story he did on bush in
the national uh guard
and as a result he was fired by cbs
and so now he's been in the wilderness
for some time
and uh he gave he was good enough to
give me a shout out for the devil's
chessboard and said you know you've been
telling the truth for a long time now
and so uh that was great to hear from
him unfortunately it ha it happens for
some of these people after they're sort
of like you know thrown overboard um i
wish it happened while they were
actually in positions of power and we
could they could do more uh you know to
enlighten the american people but yeah i
don't believe what ted koppel says i
don't believe with charlie russell uh
charlie rose rather uh you know
his point of view either
these are very mainstream people they're
not about shaking up uh you know the
national conversation they're about
putting america to sleep
which he often does for me
hi mr taylor well i finished a book this
summer by elf fletcher proudly the
secret team and i was curious
he seems to suggest that the fletcher
proud of you said proudly yes uh the
secret team he seems to suggest that the
1947 national security act seems to have
given the cia their
their power or whatever
and uh how do you feel about uh maybe
changing that i know changing the names
on airports and everything would be good
but maybe something that really
took something away from them such as
that yeah so uh elf fletcher proud
prouty was uh air force officer and an
american hero you know the american
military uh has a number of these people
throughout our history uh thankfully uh
smedley darling but uh butler uh
uh how many people know this medley
darlington butler's name
the the famous marine hero who actually
uh became a great champion of peace and
democracy
and fletcher prouty is another military
hero and people should
read his books he's not with us any
longer but
he wrote
extensively about how the national
security state was eroding democracy
and in fact was in a great position to
see this happen because he was the
liaison at one point between the air
force and alan dallas the cia so he knew
alan dell's quite well
1947 is the year that the cia is created
the national security
you know charters passed
harry truman as president
uh he later felt came to feel that he
created a frankenstein and i think proud
he probably believed the same
uh but this was the president himself
who was saying this
uh he always intended he said truman for
the cia to be nothing more than an
intelligence gathering organization that
would then
collate the best information and pass it
on to the president in the white house
but instead it became this
this action
uh
arm
that went around the world uh
overthrowing governments and
assassinating people and so on
and harry truman wrote a remarkable
op-ed piece about this in the washington
post shortly after president kennedy was
killed and really was a bombshell at the
time given the kind of traumatized state
of the nation then just weeks after
dallas and what he wrote in the
washington post was that yes that the
cia was
had become this kind of rogue agency and
that was not only endangering
democracies overseas but at home
so alan dallas was stunned by this
and he knew he couldn't let it stand
so he immediately goes into action he
tries to strong-arm harry truman who's
now
around 80 years old retired in
independence missouri
he tries to pressure truman into
withdrawing retracting his own article
uh you know but truman's a stubborn guy
famously and and refuses so dulles flies
down to missouri and personally
again puts the pressure on him and says
mr president you certainly remember that
when you created the cia you wanted it
to be this activist agency and so on
truman won't hear anything of that and
it stands by his article
so dulles does the next best thing he
can't change reality so what does he do
and this is how of course intelligence
agencies operate all the time they
change the record
so he writes a letter for the record
dulles to the general counsel of the cia
and says oh i just came back from
visiting harry truman you know he was
very uh upset to hear uh that his
article had been read that way he didn't
mean to say that he was confused about
how it actually had come through that
way he made him out to be in other words
this senile guy who didn't know what he
was doing maybe some deputy had put him
up to it and so on so that's became the
cia's official story it got picked up in
various histories and various essays
written by ci friendly historians and so
on so alan dulles was a master at that
at manipulating the truth when the truth
didn't satisfy his needs
you obviously
command a huge amount of information
related to the dulles era and especially
the kennedy assassination and all of the
enormous literature that's come out of
it and the credibility of
that material
is spotty shall we say
and i'm just curious there's um
the the story that's always sort of
alleged about the plot to sort of
involve
uh cuba more deeply in the assassination
of john kennedy but yet uh very few um
uh bits of information have ever
surfaced uh trying to make that
connection um more tangible so you mean
the allegation that fidel castro's
behind the assassination or that uh that
there was some complicity there um and i
came across a book a few years ago that
was the is the only source that i know
that really talks about that's called
jfk the second plot
by a guy named matthew smith published
in the
england
um and i'm just curious to know are you
familiar with it i'm not no
what's he say basically that the
sheriff of the adjoining county to
dallas
actually has
the
wing numbers of the airplane that was
sitting idling on the runway at the time
of the assassination with a flight plan
to cuba
and the allegation was about oswald or
someone was supposed to fly there yes
and there's there's a whole series of
connections about how the he was
supposed to be transported you know to
the airport that the the sheriff seems
to corroborate so i just thought that
was kind of an interesting tidbit that i
kept looking for in your book i just
finished it a few days ago okay um
well i can't comment uh specifically on
the book unfortunately because i haven't
read it but i will comment and i think
it's very important on this long uh
you know
complicated you know allegation that
fidel castro in cuba was somehow
involved in the assassination of
president kennedy i think it's you know
to be blunt about it it's the oldest lie
that's been told about the kennedy
assassination and in fact it was being
disseminated that lie it was a
disinformation line by the cia and its
friendly assets in the american media
and the world media while the
president's body was still warm that was
the first conspiracy theory being pumped
out about the kennedy assassination and
here's why it was preposterous i'll go
into some of the just key things at the
very moment
when president kennedy is being shot in
dallas he's meeting with a peace envoy
castro from jfk the french journalist
john danielle who's carrying an olive
branch from kennedy now this is one of
several
peace envoys who
on the president's request has gone down
to havana to try and find a way finally
to diffuse the tension
between havana and washington and as
soon as the message is delivered in
havana they find out that the
assassination
castro is devastated because he now
realizes these peace these back channel
peace negotiations are finished and he
says to uh
you know john danielle this is terrible
basically everything's changed
and then he says now watch the next
thing we'll know will hear is that
they're pinning it on me and of course
that's exactly the next broadcast from
america is connecting lee harvey oswald
to cuba through the fair play for cuba
committee
you know uh the bridge of spies film by
spielberg uh leaves one key thing out
the new film it's a you know
entertaining movie with tom hanks and so
on and it's about this guy who is an
american hero james donovan he was a new
york corporate attorney who was
recruited by kennedy to go to berlin to
uh
you know to win the release of francis
gary powers in return for uh the release
of a soviet spy
and it's a great story but he it's
presented as if he's doing this pretty
much on his own like he's a lone ranger
and as i wrote in my op-ed piece
recently in the washington post
this actually you know very
delicate diplomatic dance had the
complete support of khrushchev
in moscow and kennedy in washington
because both of these world leaders were
actually trying to defuse the cold war
and this was one of the first steps in
that direction
now they also leave out the fact uh
there's a little crawl at the end of the
movie saying oh later jim donovan was
used by kennedy to win the release of
the bay of pigs prisoners in cuba which
is true
but there's an even more interesting
story about jim donovan and kennedy in
cuba which is that after he won the
release of the bay of pig's prisoners
the kennedy brothers asked donovan again
to widen his efforts in cuba and to
establish a broader peace
understanding with castro and he went
down on more than one occasion hit it
off with castro they were both were
drinkers they loved to talk donovan and
fidel late into the night
and he was on the verge of a of a you
know forging of prostramont with havana
but
the cia was not in support of this and
when they got word of this back channel
that kennedy had set up with havana they
actually went to donovan said hey on
your next trip to cuba we understand
that fidel is a scuba enthusiast why
don't you take him this wetsuit
which he will enjoy putting on well the
wetsuit of course was infused with
poisons cooked up in the cia labs this
is a famous story of course that one of
the many ways that the cia tried to kill
caster was with a poison wetsuit so
here's the cia in one of the many cases
in which it tried to sabotage kennedy
policy and the kennedy policy aimed at
ending the cold war with moscow and
havana
and this is one of the most flagrant
ways using a peace emissaries peace
envoy who was an american hero to try
and kill castro unwittingly
so it's a remarkable story and uh you
know the cia's effort to blame castro
for what i believe actually came out of
the anti-castro plot against kennedy as
bobby kennedy figured out immediately as
attorney general
and i write about this in both my books
brothers and devil's chessboard that's
the source of the plot
not castro himself it's the anti-castro
operation that's being run by the cia
with the mafia's help that's the
blowback that killed jfk
and you know fidel castro had nothing to
do with jfk's assassination
it's sort of like force for the trees
discussion i mean i'm really awestruck
by the
minutia and the detail that you provide
which really makes it
you know show don't tell but
to me this
don't you think that the collaboration
begins before world war ii and that the
national security state was actually
born out of world war one and the whole
creation of nazi germany as a feature
of u.s foreign policy and that this
entire endless war machine is much older
than world war ii i mean if you could
yeah no
you're right and for simplicity i i kind
of focus on in the book with the world
war ii period and with dallas slipping
across the border into switzerland but i
do allude to some of the earlier history
as well and you're right
for instance sullivan and cromwell their
wall street law firm the dulles brothers
firm was uh really made a fortune off of
being sort of at the center of the
reparations game that was going on at
the time
you know to rebuild germany and that's
where they start to embed themselves uh
in these german corporate interests
and uh when hitler comes on the scene
they just sort of seamlessly go with him
as the person who's rebuilding germany
as the regime
uh but yeah it goes back to world war
one i mean really you could say
speaking of smedley butler it goes back
to the turn of the century when the
american empire first
is created in the spanish uh
american war in the philippines and cuba
and so on and those uh banana republic
wars that uh america was fighting you
know smedley butler who is this marine
hero who's forced as a young marine to
fight in all these dirty wars these
imperial wars throughout the caribbean
and central america and so on you know
said later i wasn't uh fighting for
uncle sam
i was fighting for wall street and you
know um you know he said he was
a
bigger gangster basically than al capone
so
and he said war is a racket you know he
wrote a book or as a racket so you know
he was drawing on his experience from
wars that really were starting at the
turn of the century around 1900 and that
mark twain among others as another great
american hero was crusading against and
wrote again saying america was going
down a very dark path
and
i wrote a book actually it's kind of a
graphic history
illustrated by the great spain rodriguez
the late cartoonist in spain i worked on
that
that tried to bring
you know the butler smelly butler story
to a younger audience
so yes there is more history there
what's the name of that book
devildog
do you have that
patrick
i thought you were a talbot completist
uh any other questions i have shadow
nights sorry
thank you
can you talk about angleton as a
cultural czar i think you called them
and if i can sneak in a second question
if dulles whole kind of world and milieu
is
deception and lies how do you um
how do you work through that and come to
something that seems to be a semblance
of the truth and doing research
yeah
good question so james jesus angleton
how many people know that name
legendary chief of counterintelligence
uh and the leading intellectual sort of
an artist really an artist of
of deceit
and covert action
so he was alan dallas right hand person
they go way back together uh they start
working together early during world war
ii the final days of the war
where they're very active in rome james
angleton has some deep roots in italy
his family
um he prided himself on being very
connected there and that sort of spy
versus spy atmosphere in rome right
after the war is fascinating and i try
and evoke that period you know one of
the things i tried to do by the way was
write as an anti-spy novel basically i
wanted to grip the reader and i think
the book really does pull you along with
all these amazing stories but they're
all true
um and uh so angleton is this amazing
character and one of the things he's
doing in rome is setting up these rat
lines to allow
the nazis to escape and he sets up a
kind of a luxury apartment in rome for
some of the more notorious and
flamboyant nazis
um
and uh so he you know
he has a lot of deep history with dulles
and in fact he later said he suggested
at the end of his life that the reason i
became so successful within the cia was
basically i had the goods on alan dulles
and he had to keep promoting me um and
so that's an interesting thing he also
was a catholic uh so he had something of
a conscience
kind of a soiled conscience and
as he was dying from all the cigarettes
he had smoked over the years and he was
wracked by coughs and lung cancer at the
end you know he said
the heads of the cia the great legends
of the cia like alan dallas and richard
helms were all going to end up in hell
he told a journalist who was visiting
him and he said i imagine i'll be seeing
them there shortly
he was this uh artist in a way though as
you uh suggest at yale he uh published a
very well-respected poetry journal
he knew ezra pound and hung out with the
e cummings
and he you know
he understood that the cold war was very
very much a war of ideas
and a culture war
and so under angleton and his um
deputies within the cia they pumped a
fortune into different front groups
cultural front organizations that
subsidize poets and
poetry journals and
conferences literary conferences and
magazines
including some of the more famous ones
paris review and so on
uh encounter magazines so he understood
this war as an award of ideas and
intellectual war
and um
that and he was able to create i think a
very strong cultural hegemony within
sort of the intelligentsia in this
country and in western europe
and you broke away from that at great
peril to your career really i mean
suddenly funds would dry up you didn't
get teaching positions you know
it was very effective so stalin
you know in
soviet union maybe had more brutal
methods of controlling intellectuals and
artists but certainly the the western
way the angleton way was almost even
more effective in some ways
because it was full of self it was
driven by self-censorship
and
a sense that we didn't want to break
away as an artist from this cold war
consensus so the p the few people who
did at the time were heroes i think and
one of the ones that i highlight in my
book is c wright mills
who when i was in college was you know
very well known figure because of his
book the power elite but has been
largely forgotten now
but you know he was a critic of these
cold war intellectuals he said basically
you're all about american triumphalism
and celebrating america and you sh
that's not the role of an intellectual
the role of an intellectual is to be
rigorously independent and critique
power and you've all sold out and
intellectuals like arthur schlesinger
liberals who were among the most
compromised by angleton and his cultural
funding were furious at people like at
mills and so there were great debates
between mills and schlesinger sadly you
know mills after championing the cuban
revolution he wrote a big best seller
called listen yankee he went down to
cuba and hung out with fidel and che in
the early days he died
very young i think it was late 40s in
1962 i think it was
one more
one more
um so i think a lot of your audience
here today came out
uh either inclined to believe your
particular counter narrative or with a
counter narrative of their own that they
wanted to put to you
um as someone who simply wandered in
because the topic seemed interesting
you use two terms in describing the book
one is a counter narrative which i think
means something intended to question the
common narrative the other one is a true
story which means something else
entirely especially for a historian
why
is the
you know the let's say georgetown
political science student or the mit
computer science student somebody who's
educated who has an idea of what logic
is but who may not be an expert in the
subject
why what
why should they take yours to be the
true story
that's a good question
and you really have to read the book you
know not just listening tonight to uh
look at the evidence that i compile and
the argument that i put together you
know i think speaking of arthur
schlesinger i think it was lesson she
was that history is an ongoing argument
and i understand that my book will be
challenged uh from many directions and
it is being challenged and you know
the people who have their own
ideological bias that i can see right
away that are trying to knock this story
down i dismiss those but i take to heart
actually
people who have done their own work
and
have researched
this
history as uh exhaustively as i have and
so i often learn from these dialogues
with them you know whether it's on the
internet or face to face
i understand i didn't get everything
right i didn't get the whole story
perhaps
but i really do think this is the work
of my lifetime and karen uh croft and i
worked very hard on this we've been
working basically for about 10 years on
this when you look at both my book
brothers and this book
and um
i think this book is the most complete
version of this history that we have at
this point
i expect it to you know as i say to be
challenged and to evolve maybe over time
but as of the year 2015
if you want a real understanding of what
happened in the cold war to this nation
and the rise of the secret government
and how democracy was uh undermined and
how people were killed heroes who would
fight that secret state
then i think you have to read my book
great that's a great way to end
i want to let you know too that david
will be at the howard zinn book festival
which is november 15th at the
mission
branch of city college
thank you david thank you patrick thank
you karen
thank you concerned citizens
and please i'll be signing books yes
let's get some books and where should i
be get them signed why don't you stay
there okay stay here yeah or a table
maybe
i can move these for you
okay
[Music]
here's a